please
did you listen to uh
james yeah i do i do listen to it it's
very interesting to see how
in the western world people are so
interested about the brain in africa we
don't do that
why is that
because we believe in the fact that
everybody's every single person that is
born is born with abilities that
everybody is born the same way nobody's
born bad or good
circumstances in the family where you
are born more the
adult that you are
and that's what it is my father said
always said to me your ultimate weapon
is your brain if you know how to use it
you can change you can challenge anybody
and i don't trust what people ever tell
me it has to go through my brain i have
to process it before i tell you okay
so so you wouldn't you wouldn't have
this scam of your brain you can scan my
brain i don't care
anything you want to do
your background how much has that got to
do with who you are today i mean you
grew up in benin yeah i grew up in a
family of 10 children i was number seven
and i had three brothers after me that
tried to ruin my life and i kicked them
out of my life quite quickly
to make them understand i'm older than
you don't tell me no no nonsense i'm not
taking no nonsense for nobody
and um the the good part of um the whole
story is because the fact that my mom
and father have been to school it has
transformed my life completely and they
were dedicated to the fact that we all
have to go to school to have a job
my father always used to say the best
wealth i can give you is an education
therefore you make
a good judgment on what you want to do
and then you take it from there and my
mom was much more on the half side
vaccination i hated the unicef truck
like nothing else in the world because
every time they arrive she's like oh
you're gonna do this one i'm like
no more needle
i don't like needle but she believes
that in order for you to learn good in
school you have to be in good health
good nutrition was really important and
every time we come back from school
before we touch the food she's like wash
your hand i'm like
well my hair is not dirty how do you
know
i'm like oh mom please nobody wash the
hand as much as you make us wash our
hands see i don't care what people do
outside i do what i want in my house you
don't watch that end of yours you don't
eat but but you
you you became i mean you became a
singer yourself and being a young girl
in benin in the 60s that wasn't very
common it was not common it was um what
was it accepted was it okay well i
started with my mom's theory group
actually she threw me on stage when i
was six years old
and never stopped laughing i'm like okay
i'm gonna sing until then i start
singing but the thing when it's shifted
is when you're a little girl and you
sing everybody find it cute oh she's so
cute oh she's singing so well and then
people to kick in and then they start
calling you prostitute
yeah if you sing you're prostitute if
you're a boy you do music you're a drug
addict that's just that's what it is i
mean there's no in between so you will
be walking back from school and people
is throwing stone at you spilling and
you calling your kind of name
and i remember when i was 12 years old i
came back from school i was like what
did i do to deserve this
and i was crying and my grandmother my
mother's mother was there
she was much more worried about me being
hurt physically and i said i don't want
to sing anymore
she she cleaned me up and she said okay
sit down what is the deal so i said they
called me bro you don't want to sing
anymore. she said well
i can't tell you what to do i just can
give you an advice and you do whatever
you want to do it in your life you have
to understand
that in this world you cannot love
everybody and please everybody it goes
both ways
if
what you doing makes you happy and your
family supported it let them speak
jealousy will never get out of this life
what you decide to do
you stand on your ground and you do it
with your heart your bread and your guts
and stand on it and that's what i do
i mean today you
you you have you have a long singing
career you've seen more than four
languages i think in portuguese too in
portuguese too uh does it
how's i mean i don't know if you
demonstrate but is it is it a
it's a completely different language for
example you say
because you have the rhythmic of the
language you have the tone of it
and
in my father's language form for example
three and five
are written the same way but the accent
is different
three you say atom five you say atom
so if you don't put the accent where
it's supposed to go
you're in trouble or good
i won't even try no good or good
something that is really good is
something that is rotten it's the same
word
good is enyo
rotten is enyo
so it's not a huge difference
it depends who you're telling it to you
don't want to run fast
where do you feel in what language do
you what do you feel at home musically i
mean all languages music is in itself is
an universal language
my parents never raised me telling me
that because i've come from africa i
cannot sing in any language i have no
boundary at all i can do any kind of
music because all music comes from
africa because we are all africans
period you like it or not you accept it
or not you cannot do rock and roll
without the blues who brought the blues
to america yeah come on
even one you should come for africa oh
absolutely yes it's the same chord sorry
yeah
can't help it i gotta take that i gotta
put that in there
and
uh it it's you you mentioned
unicef and you've been you've been
working for unicef since 2002
yes for many years
so you you've seen not only the best of
africa you also see the worst africa is
a continent
you cannot tell a story of a continent
well one way
everyone have a double face but the
westerner are so focused on telling just
the misery story that is like we cannot
get ourselves from the ground up
who built our own if you want to be rude
the westerners are the ones that are
going to have the contract to do it they
don't teach people heads is killing
africa you bring the money you do your
thing everybody's in their bubble
we're coming to help you but the african
people are never part of it how can you
help somebody without asking the person
what do you need and how can we do it
together
show people how to fish don't give them
the fish
putting all those foundations nothing is
changing we are not transforming the
life of the people but we are just there
for our own ego to sit down the tv going
i build this i do this how many africans
work with you
how many african do you help
do you teach how to build a well but but
i'm asking i'm asking you now as a
unicef ambassador but also as a west
african
what is happening now with ebola ebola
is showing really that colonization is
still going on
poverty is politically made and they
made it in africa and they are
implemented in here
because if they can make so many people
poor in africa they will do it in the
country to keep the power everybody is
looking at china we want to be as china
can i have no democracy why should we
give democracy to our people i mean
everything is linked if you think
that ebola are not gonna come here
you're not living on planet earth
i can tell you that because you can't
stop people from going from one place to
the other and you don't help people in
africa sooner or later it's gonna come
and impact you it does not matter how
hard you try no money can save you from
death i don't care how rich you are
you're certainly not only a great singer
you're also an activist
and as we can hear now i have to be
because i i believe in the connectivity
that we have for me a human being has
never been a matter of color i never
grew up in even in benin i never grew up
thinking about anybody being white black
yellow or red i don't care i really i
don't because
your brain
is the same color as mine
and who knows the color of a soul
where is the color of a soul if you told
me the the the the brain anywhere else i
could show you exactly right now
i don't want you to be talking about my
brain
everybody have the same
if you you you do my head it's gonna be
the same and we keep on
constantly
thinking
that if we ditch the other person we're
gonna feel better i don't think so for
me every time i can empower somebody
to take lead in its own life to go from
one step to the other
that's all i need because you see it
bloom and it's not in your hand anymore
give people the responsibility to do
what they want to do i don't believe in
guilt for one bit my father said in my
house there's never gonna be any guilt
you do something wrong excuse yourself
guilt is a poison that eats you from
inside
let that be the final word and
and i really hope you will keep up all
your good work
thank you so much
please welcome james fallon
all right